quando telecom italia ha cominciato di
capire che la vendita dei servizi presi
precedenti non andavo più avanti siano
inventato o hanno accettato l'invenzione
che qualche poeta che ha parlato di
cloud computing fa computing non c'è
claudio forse il check in chiusi però
l'immagine parlava e ha creato un
industria big data e l'industria del
momento ne parliamo di più smart city
chi non ne ha parlato se di parlare di
smart city no cioè di print abbiamo
sentito una bellissima presentazione
sicily prince e anche questo è un buzz
ward che la gente usa non vuol dire che
non devono farlo però vuol dire che c'è
una concentrazione di interesse su
questi post parte del nostro linguaggio
comune internet of things e uno di
questo puzzle che adesso sta prendendo
un vero volo è assolutamente pertinente
di nuovo per il business perché il
business the internet of games per data
analytics per l'uso dei big data per la
contestualizzazione
noi abbiamo sentito già un sacco oggi
sulla domanda è assolutamente una una
spinta pertinente per internet internet
spip è già un vaso orario forse non so
se i organizzatore lo sappiano però c'è
un undici sono libri su internet tipo ci
sono ci sono siti web su internet c'è
tutta una marea di unindustria su questo
basware domeniche di male questo è
l'internet delle cose che dà la
molteplicità fenomenale delle varie cose
del mondo dell'energia della costruzione
del della della casa della salute
dell'industria trasporto tutti questi
cosi il varietà sono cose adesso
disponibile grazie a questi interesse
delle cose l'articolo che
vi raccomando veramente di leggere parla
del fatto che non che la gente non non
capiscono il pericolo che vivono e che
non conoscono non si reggono veramente
conto del danno che può fare
l'internet delle cose la risposta a
questo è la narcosi di narciso inventata
che ma cruel per dire che noi siamo
assolutamente innamorati delle nostre
macchine e più di tutto dei nostri
telefonini e dei nostri computer come al
passato era innamorato del sistema di
trasporto adesso mettiamo il nostro
cuore infatti adesso non ha proprio più
il suo nome ha parlato del computer come
essendo un amico una presenza nella
nostra vita abbiamo una narcosi reciso
certamente abbiamo anche questa cosa la
paura no che è sempre più grande
l'ansia che viene a partire del fatto
che siamo tracciati tracciabili e stiamo
sviluppando ciascuno di noi o no è no
anzi persone stanno sviluppando per noi
un inconscio digitale che col dire che
voglia di croce digitale e tutto che si
sa su di ciascuno di noi ma che noi non
sappiamo che viene di tutti i profili
che viene di tutti
classifica che viene di tutte le cose
che abbiamo comprato che viene dello
stato di salute che viene di tutta la
personalizzazione di che abbiamo sentite
parlare oggi è assolutamente un buon
senso però è per questo che vale la pena
di rivedere la cosa sul piano psico
storico chico storico
siamo a sviluppare un altro tipo umano è
certamente un altro tipo di inconscio
che è un'influenza sulla nostra vita
assolutamente così grande di quello di
frayn o quello di young è un inconscio
che sistema sempre di più la nostra
personalizzazione vale distribuisce
anche fuori vuol dire che tutte queste
fonti di informazione che sono
disponibile a qualcuno che sai fare un
po di ricerca non è anche di essere agio
no non voglio non prendo il tempo di
dire tutto per espressioni di me di
tario ripete shaun che compro tutto
questo si mette insieme 64 informazioni
su ciascuno di noi come consumatore
ordinario di una città come milano o
come torino vuol dire una una fonte di
informazione che non lo sappiamo questo
ma che raramente definitiva al problema
è questo big data
il grande inquisitore che ti fa la
domanda senza torturare il corpo ormai
non rigidi porti e riprovati minority
report e adesso il futuro potrebbe
adesso si tratta di prender analysis non
solo di data analysis nel senso che
s'apre vecchi vandalismo dire andiamo
verso questo allora aveva questa storia
che barzelletta questo ragazzo lo farà
vuol dire che possiamo già vedere il
criminale prima che ha avuta la chiamo
la possibilità di di fare qualche sia
penso che se c'è qualcosa che volevo far
pensare oltre delle varie idee che
volesse dire il fa tutti e dobbiamo
abituarci a riconoscere il fatto che
abbiamo tre spazi principali da occupare
questo bello questo di ciascuno di noi
e questo questo questa rete questo
spazio virtuale sono spazi fondamentali
hanno qualità proprietà sono
culturalmente occupabili ero
psicologicamente e crea situazioni
totalmente diverse che quello che
abbiamo avuto fino adesso vediamo
non possiamo non sono con esso non posso
farvi vedere questo questo è un modo di
abitare lo spazio con la rete un modo
assolutamente nuovo di relazionare in
tempo reale con tutte le persone che
sono presenti nella città di manhattan e
una circolazione una visualizzazione
anche le nostre delle relazioni che
assolutamente fenomenale abitare la
mente con la rete essere completamente
sciamo occupato mentalmente di questi
prodotti è uno schermo abbiamo sentito
parlare di schermo anche oggi che
impiegano un po che prendono poste del
nostro pensiero è che fanno che su
schermo emigrano tutte le nostre facoltà
interne rovesciamento del pubblico e del
privato essendo uno di conseguenza che
stiamo a vedere adesso nelle condizioni
attuali della nostra relazione con la
rete parlo sempre dal punto di vista
della persona che succede con la persona
a partire dal momento che è con esatto
le altre persone via la rete e altri
altri questo rovesciamento pubblico
privato è stato veramente un problema
civil azionale non semplicemente un
momento è una cosa la nostra
indipendenza
la nostra dipendenza la nostra vita
privata quello che pensiamo e da nove
stato diventata del nostro rapporto con
la lettura e la scrittura e oggi perché
leggere vuol dire prendere il potere su
un linguaggio un potere più privato sul
linguaggio ma questo potere privato sul
linguaggio non abbiamo più quando si
diceva che l'internet libera la vita
sì è vero la liberatà meraviglioso se
volevo i primi a dire che era una cosa
fenomenale lo è però porta con sé un
sacco di problemi e trovare i problemi e
questa perdita graduale insensibile
della nostra identità privata che più di
tutto della proprietà delle nostre
pensieri ricordatevi che io dico le cose
che volevo dire non dico quello che non
voglio dire basta sono le mie penso che
sono in yeti si oralmente un problema ma
sulla rete mai tutte le cose che
facciamo sulla rete solo propone zan del
mondo intero allora questo fa un diciamo
c'è una domanda su che pensare ad
esempio il ritorno della cultura del
vergogna ricordatevi che la vergogna era
la qualità della responsabilità di una
persona e nella società tribale ora le
la mia responsabilità e verso il padre
verso la famiglia verso le tribune sono
l'altro appena incominciate del leggere
e di prendere il potere suo linguaggio
interiorizza tutto questo e non è più
vergogna la mia responsabilità e verso
di me e se dovesse il di me il mio
destino e la mia responsabilità e sono
colpevole di nuovo frank che ha sfiorato
la colpa del nostro della stria di vita
oggi tutto questo fa che che conta è il
reputation capitan per noi per noi per
il business per qualche cosa che succede
allora domanda è sempre cattivi invitata
non sempre questo mi piace molto
questo è un tratto della sede della
sensibilità americana
la sera prima del capodanno o durante il
capodanno sono tutti i tweet che
invecchiano precisamente verso il mio
pensiero e verso l'altro perché l'alta
padano si fa la risoluzione che come
saronno
prossimo no e allora tutti quelli in
rosa sono quelli che sono orientato
verso l'altro no sono e una pressione
big data da the analysis prende tutti i
suoi simboli sanamente analizza la
quantità e fa tutto
l'analisi statistica che si può fare
allora quello che sono in blu sono
invece sarò io farò più sporchi e sono
più così
no verso di sé e allora è evidente il
verde per americani e il denaro la cosa
che volevo avere la prova carina questa
perché fa infatti le statistiche globali
o nazionale o sociale sono infinitamente
più raffinati e possono andare la
pittura diciamola la fotografia delle
emozioni a questo momento collettiva
però anche un altro beneficio menici tu
la trasparenza se siamo tutti i ciociari
si tutto si può sapere su di noi siamo
nudi
se siamo lunghi come comportarci però
ciao ma continuare peggiore che come
adamo eva i vestiti bastano infatti non
va
non c'è un vestito che ti aiuta in
questi milita non c'è un vestito allora
i panama papers vicini ci vedete la
storia e così se la racconta su di jean
louis nei nove che dice siamo
trasparenti che un problema posso anche
pensare che evolve questo tipo itt ma
fondamentalmente la società sta tornando
trasparente e lo sarà sempre di più
wikileaks ed un punto di partenza
però adesso siamo arrivano il pane ma
papers vuol dire che la gente che fino
adesso viveva nel nascosti tranquillo no
no assolutamente non adesso tutto si può
sapere e tutto si può sapere sempre di
più questo è una diciamo questo più
donne stato positivo perché può soste
posso pregare che la metà del prodotto
nazionale del denaro disponibile per il
pre servizi pubbliche
è rovinata dalla sparire di queste di
questi evasori fiscali
beh vediamo che la giustizia sociale
sarà più forte nel futuro
parlavo delle cose delle persone altro
beneficio dell'internet delle cose
perché infatti questo è la stessa mappa
dell'altro salvi che porta a questa
volta su diverse cose che concerne le
persone individuale studiate a partire
dei di webos ma di queste cose che si
portano studiano il tuo corpo possono
avere un infinità di informazione che
viene il tipo di personalizzazione da
che abbiamo sentito parlare molto bene
oggi perché evidentemente sapeva stiamo
arrivando a una come dire una conoscenza
dei ciascun individuo che è molto forte
il quanti files è la parola che dicano
per l'uso di vigata per sapere che sono
le vari aspetti delle condizioni del suo
corpo secondo una studio sul tema
in termini più o meno meno lungo la cosa
che può fare è persa e questo ricordo
marini levi che ha parlato
brillantemente di questo centro che il
laboratorio che ha creato per me usare
della stampante 3d già si sa che si può
fare che su tv non biologici però si può
fare anche molecole che sono
precisamente costruite per rispondere a
questo cancro che è assolutamente unico
nel mondo futuro fenomenale che viene
dell'internet delle cose che veramente
sono per le persone
la cosa che è concluso su questa è una
cosa che dobbiamo pensare che internet
internet o film easy solo uno tutte le
forme di punizione che facciamo su
internet tre hanno un nuovo tipo di
corpo sociale e anche il nuovo tipo di
individuale e un sistema limbico sapete
che il sistema limbico è quello che
porta le emozioni
e quello che fisicamente fa crescere il
sentimento di paura di amore di
desiderio qualche si sa è che porta
dall'emozione all'azione
ogni tanto il sistema limbico oggi è
veramente questo sistema di social media
e varie i modi che si rifanno la mappa
del mondo e creano situazione di
collezione che sono totalmente diverse
del passato allora questa è l'ultima
snai non è molto bella però volevo
semplice dire che o negli aspetti più
strani della rivoluzione digitale della
condizione di internet austin istituito
il resto è il fatto che è basata sulle
necessità e anche il nostro corpo è
basato sulle necessità e trasporti tutta
la segnalazione della vita è fondata sui
movimenti elettrici dietro il corpo
dentro e foglie il corpo c'è questa
collezione è sempre una sensazione più
intima per esempio adesso si può pensare
con un casco e vedere l'effetto del suo
pensiero su schermo si può pagare alla
macchina per farlo per cento euro online
l'intimità del noto trasporto personale
con il resto è assolutamente crescente
allora se si pensa come diceva m che
abbiamo esternalizzato il nostro sistema
nervoso centrale e lavoriamo
globalizzato la domanda è un po paurosa
ma su di che per sempre esempio il
bellissimo discorso del relatore di
terra madre sarebbe certamente d'accordo
e possibile che una volta che perché a
schiera sicuro eve la nostra sicurezza
comincia un movimento
diciamo riferibilità talmente forte che
la connessione tra l'eliminazione dei
pericoli l'eliminazione dei disagi le
eliminazioni cose delle ineguaglianze
che cessi puoi immaginare che un una
possibilità di maturazione di internet
of things evidentemente tpp sono
precisamente un'interconnessione
talmente intima termino su questo
situazione anche di macrolane
sciovinisti information wiiware o manca
en scène nell'era dell'informazione
indossiamo l'umanità intera come
distinzione della nostra pelle grazie